people see climate change as an actual
existential risk when they say
existential risk permanent unrecoverable
collapse or we are basically permanently
locked into being in the Stone Age and
we can't get back out of it again almost
all of the things that people focus
their attention on stuff like climate
change even nuclear war every nuke goes
off not an existential risk underlying
super intelligent AGI big existential
risk nanotechnology big existential risk
engineered pandemics big existential
risk I am blown away by the fact that of
all of the Myriad of different X risks
that we could be focused on climate
change is the one that's galvanized the
most public attention and Toby's book
The precipice says it's got a one in ten
thousand chance over the next hundred
years of being the end of human
civilization whereas I think agis 1 in
10 engineered pandemics are one in ten
natural pandemics are 1 in 30. basically
it seems like all of the attention is
focused on something which doesn't
require it or deserve it why